one thing I thought about recently was
you know talking talking about things
that like fell off is it is it just a me
thing or has Pixar kind of fallen off
oh
I think it's not so much they've fallen
off I think it's just a matter of we
just grew up and we're not really
hearing about ourselves
because name the best recent film
they've made
is cocoa
I want to guess too
I think it's like four or five what the
[__] off
never mind
how many have there wait when did wait
Coco came out 26 17 18 19 something like
that it was before the pandemic right
2017. what the [__] how many films are
really I'm pretty sure they released
like a how many how many have they done
since Coco to now
another good one recently which was a
massive flaw dude well yeah I mean this
is like have you guys only been having
flops as well yeah yeah because do you
remember back in the day when we were
growing up pretty much every Pixar movie
just became like a classic you know
everyone looks at [__] like Toy Story
Monsters Inc The Incredibles [__]
Ratatouille up you know there's a reason
why they still get memed to this day
it's because they've stayed within our
Collective Consciousness because that's
how important you know you could
normally tell this is the new way to
tell if something is a classic or not
how often does it still get memes years
after this release Breaking Bad you know
sure that still gets memes and [__] like
that you know you don't see any Game of
Thrones memes anymore that just that
just shows you know but uh so yeah
what what no way wait since Coco there's
been 23 Pixar films
can you name all of them
oh
holy [__] can you can you name all the
films they've released
20 something Luca 22 versus tomorrow's
soul out on moon Loop wind float yeah
that's a Toy Story 4 yeah it sucks
especially Brad Auntie yeah they fell
off
the only one I recognized from there was
Toy Story 4. and that movie sucked
well I remember okay yeah the fell off I
I remember uh you know how high they
were these two films
maybe they should have released yeah
maybe they should have done yeah I don't
know what happened with them because uh
like like I said a lot of their films to
me are Classics I'm trying to figure out
when exactly they fell off like was
there well it was that falling off I
think it's hard to they've had a lot
more competition you know elimination
yeah they're crushing it right now his
illumination competition they made the
Mario movie yeah I know uh do you know
how [__] profitable the Minions
movies were I'm not talking about
profitability here I'm talking about the
art of filmmaking Journey
like this is a masterpiece let's be real
the most popular animated piece of media
in like the past 10 years is [__]
minions don't say that
don't say that this is the reality I
remember the good old days where people
look The Toy Story and Incredibles and
Monsters Inc and those were the and
those were the Peaks that everyone
talked about minions they for better or
worse they are the they they crush and
so they've been doing that and then
obviously the Mario movie and now
there's the other talks about the Zelda
movie or whatever yeah
um and then also DreamWorks is kind of
doing okay sometimes as the classic
DreamWorks formula of one Banger movie
followed by one dog [__] movie they
always do this because they released uh
Puss in Boots which was have you guys
watched it no no [__] Puss in Boots are
so good yeah it's insane yeah you know I
don't even watch the first the second
one's so [__] good it's so you don't
need to watch this you didn't watch the
first one do you know how much context
you've missed out Connor [__] off this
is like when John Wick said yeah
it's not when John Wick said yeah he got
excommunicado and you wouldn't know that
because you didn't watch the [__]
movie you did not get asked me to color
the point is the Puss in Boots too it
was an absolute [__] Masterpiece uh
and then they released teenage Kraken
I think kind of fell off oh Ghibli oh
they released that new movie yeah they
they didn't release anything about it
one poster for it and that was their
entire marketing I've heard it's like
good but I don't [__] know anything
about it because they never [__]
promoted and then the last couple of
moves before then were just like
um
can't fall off if you never fell on yeah
I know this new movie
[Laughter]
yeah I know it because everyone's like
yeah it's good it's a little weird yeah
unless you know it's meh cause they're
saying it's weird
because I feel like typically always
struggles with like hey uh I mean we try
to talk about yeah like to me if it's
just like a Ghibli movie I'm just like
without Miyazaki uh that's how you know
you know
sorry it's got him involved with it yeah
he came back out of retirement for the
fifth no no no what I'm saying is oh as
like uh as like a Animation Studio yeah
I especially you know I'm not obviously
I've said this before I've never really
been a big fan of Ghibli movies but
especially Ghibli movies without
Miyazaki holy [__] no that's not true
there's a couple of like yonobayashi
films that are actually really really
good I mean like when Manny was there I
[__] cried to that that was a great
film that was no Miyazaki whatsoever and
then there are some Miyazaki films where
I'm like this is [__]
so yeah Turner sucks I I think that's
boring as [__] yeah but you didn't grow
up with it I was like what is this like
the [__] trains of uh
movies I was Spirited Away for the first
time
it was all right
that's all right and I was like did you
get a little this for all this stuff
like have
the [__] you know how much weird [__]
was in that belt do you know how any how
much weird stuff this man this man was
huffing something when he made this film
no there's not enough height it's just
not enough IQ I guess I just didn't
understand everything I didn't
understand that the the the I mean I
understood that the pollution was bad
because you didn't watch enough Rick and
Morty yeah [__] I mean it's just always
so weird man it's like it's all I I
always I I do find it fascinating and
I'm glad that these movies exist where
it's like PG but [__] up it's like
every Ghibli movie is like yeah it's
just it's family friendly yeah I don't
know I wouldn't say Princess Mononoke
his family friends yeah but I feel like
a lot of the films like house is like
yeah it's a fun movie
because the trailers could easily sell
it it's like yeah Hal's got a castle
that moves oh boy it's an adventure and
then it's got a talking flame yeah he's
a scarecrow yeah and they make him
breakfast sometimes and then they get
into the second half of the film's like
war crimes oh okay all right guys man
it's melting in his room yeah this is a
family-friendly movie yeah
what the [__] why are we going with this
the fact that Spirited Away exists and I
think it's I mean what me watching any
Ghibli movie is uh I do like it as well
it's it's kind of like me watching any
like you know kind of like any Oscar Bay
kind of like nominated video not made in
film where I'm like critically I'm like
this is [__] incredible personally
like personal attachment I'm like yeah
you know yeah I watched uh I don't think
I don't think it was maybe it was Oscar
bait it felt like it uh 1913. do you
watch that the war movie 1970 no 1913.
is that the one by Christopher Nolan no
okay I don't think so that's Dunkirk
that's dunker oh yeah uh that's yeah
you're the one on about one yes yes it's
1917 yeah yeah it's all one shot and it
was just like I actually think I would
prefer that if it wasn't all one shot
and it's kind of weird because you
always I don't know it felt like a like
a thing that was like because it also
released a peak Oscar season uh and it
just felt like it was trying to get the
like motion award Motion Picture award
for like best Cinema why is that always
they want like everything yeah like do
you think do you think directors like
sit in a circle and it's just like guys
I want to make a movie that is going to
get Awards World War II okay
like I saw
God
absolute movie is just it's always War
film human drama there's no no other
genres alive maybe there's a story in
World War II we haven't told yet I think
there's a lot of people especially older
people have very strong feelings about
it
yeah yeah yeah I think people make sense
crowd or have some kind of or the
heroics of it I think there's a lot to
tap into there that makes for really
compelling stories yeah there is is it
easy to phone it in yeah but it's like
I think to people alive today there's no
other event that is like that big and
when are we getting the pandemic that's
what I want well that's not gonna be
good though [__] oh what if it's done in
one card
probably like no it'll turn into a
political thing I think like World War
II is not a political wow
you're generally on uh you're all on the
same side of thought that it was you
know we won good job as well done Pat in
the back what I'm trying to say is like
pandemic they'd be like the Republicans
be like no no they're down here no like
you know obviously but what I meant to
say not not yeah you didn't let me
[__] finish my point I knew I knew
what your point was but just out of
context and I get what you're trying to
say about it just saying uh possibly
like the big one of the biggest Wars in
all of human history
that's uh in terms of like encapsulated
most of the countries in the world was
not political the modern day outlook of
looking at the war is not a very uh
controversial political taste right it's
more like a yes yeah we beat the bad
guys like celebrate let's make 15
million degrees about Saving Private
Ryan yeah you know and so I think that's
you know but that's why a lot of the
really interesting movies are ones that
look um taken on the perspective of
maybe other sides or maybe ones that are
set in really interesting periods during
the war well well yeah well it's it's
also like the interesting debate of you
know you look at something like World
War and you say it's like not political
and stuff like that well not not how we
no no in like the modern list like I get
what you're trying to say but I guess
the older I've gotten The more I've kind
of realized that the way that history
was taught in school is very very
different depending on which side you're
on and which country you were born in
right politics and the way we look back
is history is written by or whoever like
tells it whoever it's well as a saying
is uh history is written by the Victor
yeah history is written by The Victors
well that's why like for example one war
film or I guess a set of War films that
I always thought was like kind of
underappreciated was the um the Clint
Eastwood War film where he told it he
made two different movies from two
different sides so like the Japanese one
was the lettuce to Iwo Jima film yeah
and then the English one was All Quiet
on the Western Front I think it's one of
those questions that's a different one
it's uh what the [__] was it it was in
the other one told from the perspective
of the American side of things but like
I feel though that was really cool
because it's like you got a separate
films that specifically you know shown a
light on both sides of the war and then
after you realize you watch those two
films it's like oh no one was the winner
everyone got [__] up everyone was the
culprit and like I feel war movies need
to do that a little bit more just so
it's like it's not just a [__] like
rat race of like Yeah Yeah country one
let's go America type of thing yeah
that's what I meant by the political
yeah the good versus bad narrative is
very easy to sell yeah it is very easy
but obviously there's a lot more more to
it more Nuance not just in like movies
but just in the way history is told and
taught because history is never unbiased
and the more I grow up the more I
realized actually that
what that just reminds me
so when I first started dating Sydney
right oh God I know the quote yeah
he's [__] grilled her about this for
ages
when I first started dating Sydney uh we
were having like this I can't remember
what the debate was but it was something
to do with Wars okay uh and then Sydney
just goes yeah America's never lost the
war
and I'm like and I'm like uh I mean uh
what what do you think of the Vietnam
War and she's like oh no we won that
I wonder if that is like yeah she was
and Sydney was talking about her maybe
Sydney just took away that from her
lessons
like according to her and I
I The more I've talked to uh Americans
especially you know
especially uh people and kids who did
not grow in like the Vietnam War era are
at least uh the conversations I've had
in Wisconsin that is that is definitely
a very much
okay because I I at first I thought this
was a Sydney thing I'm like actually
just a family yeah so I you know asked
like a lot of her families and friends
when we get drunk I'm like so so random
question who won the Vietnam War
and everyone's like we want it we killed
more people America yeah Freedom baby
and I'm like I know I'm like so wait
wait so you're telling me that you came
to a country for a certain purpose you
lost so many people because you know the
you you know you lost so many people and
you're like it's not worth this anymore
let's Retreat and they're like all right
it was a draw it's just like yo we
[__] clapped but you know how many
people we killed and I'm like oh we're
the our KD ratio was higher half of them
[__] civilians
also does is City aware that America had
a civil war you know where they also
kind of lost in some respect they lost
each other so yeah I mean obviously I
mean you can you can frame like you
could take any statistical point and be
like well they won like because I think
I think like I think in World War II
like on average like a German soldier
would would end up killing more people
than any other Soldier yeah uh whether
it was good or bad so you'd be like yeah
the German soldiers are the best
it's like France surrenders haha but I
think like
pre-World War one and two I think of
like battles because of Napoleon France
had like the most wins to losses of any
country in battles
like I doubt the French like you know
like when they look back on like yeah
when we surrendered they're not like oh
we didn't surrender we were actually the
bigger man like we we stepped out so
technically we won but like sure you
know it's it's easy to laugh at uh haha
funny America I think they win every day
but like all right we live in the one
country where they're gonna talk [__]
about a lot of the a lot of the bad
history uh that's true yeah you know in
the you know it's very questionable I
think a lot of the times what history is
taught what is it but then also it's
like I guess the the other argument be
like what purpose does it have to teach
that and I think a lot of the main items
is that you need to need to be taught
this stuff to learn from it yes of
course history doesn't repeat yeah if
you're if you or your country did [__]
up things uh you should learn about it
like I think I think in the UK we should
learn more about how maybe we didn't
have the best effect on everywhere we
went to yeah because we weren't taught
any of that [__] we're just like look at
the map of all the colonies aren't they
great we did such good work now don't
worry about what happened to them in
modern day times yeah